-Our next guest is a talente
actress and comedian
you know from her work as
Meredith on "The Office."
Every episode of "The Office
is now streaming on Peacock.
Please welcome to the show
our friend Kate Flannery.
Hi, Kate!
-Hey, Seth! How are ya?
-I'm good.
I'm always so happy to see you
Kate, I knew your history
as an improviser in Chicago.
I did not know
you were from Philly.
Is that someplace
you get back to often?
-I do.
I'm one of seven kids,
and my dad is --
he's still kickin'.
He's the best.
He's in his 90s.
He's hilarious.
And, yeah, I try to get home
as much as I can.
I was just home in October
I got to, like, quarantine
for two weeks
in my friend's garage apartmen
and then spend time with my dad.
So I kind of felt like Fonzi
for a few weeks.
-[ Laughs ]
You got the Fonzie life.
-I did. It was awesome.
-You mentioned
you're one of seven.
You're the youngest of seven
Is that right?
-I am.
I have a fraternal twin sister
but technically,
I'm the youngest.
-Gotcha.
-Damn it. [ Chuckles ]
-And now, do you feel like
being the youngest of seven,
can you track back
in your life's journey
that that maybe is why
you're in show business?
-Absolutely. 300%.
I mean, I don't know why
I even bother
to spend money on a therapist,
it's so stereotypical.
-You were a Chicago improviser
Those must have been formative
and exciting years for you
-The greatest. The greatest.
I mean, you know, it's funny
I work a lot
with Jane Lynch now.
We do a live show together
and we did a Christmas album
together.
But I realized, I figured ou
the very, very first time
I ever went to Second City
Jane Lynch was onstage
understudying for Bonnie Hun
'cause it was
Bonnie Hunt's wedding day.
And then Bonnie Hunt came back
to do the improv set
in her wedding gown.
-[ Laughs ]
That's pretty good.
I don't think my wife
would have been psyched
on our wedding night if I told
her I was off to do some improv.
-I think that's why
she's divorced now.
[ Laughter ]
-They say you can usually
see the signs.
You can usually see the signs.
-You can't take off one night?
One night?
You can't miss one show?!
-I -- It's amazing
you said that.
The first time --
One of the first times
I went to Second City,
I saw Tina Fey understudying
for John Glaser.
And it is -- I mean, when yo
look back at how lucky we were
it was crazy
who you would just see
that then over the course
of the following two decades
has been exactly as successful
as you kind of hoped they'd be
when you first saw them onstage.
-Absolutely. No, it's amazing.
And then, like, I also remembe
when I was there,
John Favreau could not get hired
at Second City.
He was literally a host.
He was seating people.
[ Laughter ]
-He's -- It's a shame
it didn't work out for him
-Too bad. That's a shame.
-So, "The Office" now
is not just on Peacock,
but also sort of these
extra long episodes,
which are really fun for people.
I feel a growing number
of people
who continue to become fan
of the show every day.
What was your audition process
for "The Office" like?
-Well, initially, I auditioned
for the part of Jan,
who's Michael's boss, played b
the beautiful Melora Hardin.
Clearly, they went
in a different way.
So I actually was not
in the pilot.
And I ended up replacing
somebody,
and they kind of did...
I don't know, I think they wer
trying to figure out
who everybody was.
So I'm not even sure who..
I wasn't even sure
that Meredith --
I mean, I had no idea
she was gonna become
a drunk or a floozy.
But, you know,
my dad owns a bar.
You know, my dad owned
Flannery's Tavern for years,
so I feel like,
playing an alcoholic,
I come by it quite honestly.
-It's really, um...
Don't take this the wrong way.
It seems really cliché
to be a Flannery whose dad owned
a bar called Flannery's Tavern
-I know. I know.
-[ Laughs ]
-You know what?
Irish people, we don't get upset
about that stuff.
We just don't.
You know, I mean, Seth,
I always say,
if you can't type, stereotype.
Right?
[ Laughter ]
I mean, it's like,
this is who we -- I --
Why not be loud and proud
of who I am, you know?
-Now, you mentioned
you didn't know
what the character was gonna
develop into.
Like, what was the process like?
Did it sort of very slowly
reveal itself over time?
-Yes.
-Did writers tell new advance?
-Nobody told me in advance
But I do remember the firs
Halloween episode
during season two,
that's when I had
my first monologue
about being an alcoholic.
And I guess it was so dark
that the network decided
not to use it.
So we had to wait till Christmas
to reveal that Meredith
was a drunk.
[ Laughter ]
-I think we all -- Yeah.
I mean, by Christmas,
there's no secrets anymore
-Right? I mean...
-Meredith ended up --
you wouldn't have probably
guessed this
from our first
introduction to her --
a fair amount of stunts
over the years.
-Yes!
-Did you participate
in the stunts?
What was your level of
engagement with those?
-I did most of my own stunts
on the show.
I actually kind of loved it.
I just remember
the first season, like,
Greg Daniels had asked me
to dress up like Madonna
and they were just doing
a still picture
with Rainn Wilson
and Steve Carell
as Crockett and Tubbs.
And so I was like,
"Yeah, I'll be Madonna."
Like, anything -- I was just
up for almost anything.
I did not set my hair on fir
in the Christmas episode,
"Moroccan Christmas."
And I didn't shave my head
in the lice episode
the last season.
But other than that,
I've done every...
I got hit by the car,
I had the bat on the head,
the bag and the -- you know.
You know, I -- everything.
Did it all.
-What's the prep like
when you're, you know, somebod
with an improv background
about to be hit by a car
on a comedy show?
-[ Laughs ] Well, there wa
a safety meeting.
And Greg Daniels was tryin
to get me all, like, loose
We were doing jumping jacks.
And I just had to kind of roll
onto the grass and then roll
off the car onto a giant mat
[ Laughing ] That was it.
And I literally think the
editor, Dave Rogers,
pushed me a little bit
right before we started
just to give me the momentum
So it was a team effort.
-Nice crew.
-I did not do this by --
I cannot take credit by myself
-It takes a village to get hit
by a car on "The Office."
[ Laughter ]
-Back in your Chicago improv
days, which would make sense -
that was when SNL was going an
finding people to audition
so you actually auditioned
for SNL
I guess in the '90s, right
-Yeah, I was up for SNL.
Lorne Michaels came to a sho
I did at the Annoyance Theatre
I was also at Second City,
but I did another show
at the Annoyance.
And he brought his good budd
Quincy Jones, as you do.
-[ Laughs ]
-Sitting in these crappy
folding chairs.
And I think we had to do
the show on a Tuesday night.
They had to move the show
because he was coming.
And then we had lunch
the next day.
And he also was looking at three
other women from the show.
And so, Mike Shoemaker,
your producer,
was with Lorne at the time
'cause he used to work on SNL.
And so, the process was that you
would walk to lunch with Lorne
and then have lunch, and the
switch and be with Michael
or the opposite.
So you'd always have somebod
to be -- like, let them have a
private conversation close by,
if that makes any sense?
-Yeah.
I mean, it doesn't make sense,
but Lorne would do that.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
You know,
and the thing is, like,
I'm friends with the other women
that's being considered.
It was Melanie Hutsell, an
she ended up getting the job
And like, of course,
I'm, like, so Catholic
that I kind of didn't know
what to do.
You know, like, you don't want
to be a douche bag.
You want to be happy
for your friends.
But, you know, thousands
of dollars of therapy later,
you go, "Okay,
I guess I had a right
to be a little bummed
about that. That's okay."
-Yeah, of course.
-That's alright.
-Well, I think all of us
are so happy
that it worked out
the way it did.
It is such a delight to go bac
and watch that show
that is just -- it not onl
maintained its excellence,
it just holds so well.
It just keeps so well.
And you're such a big
part of it.
Thanks so much
for being here, Kate.
-Thank you so much, Seth.
You're the best.
-We'll see you next time.
Every season of "The Office" i
currently streaming on Peacock